is all of this just reaction is it still
this big hangover from Trump being
elected partly I mean I'm sure there's a
frustration about it
Trump I suppose was the start of it
wasn't that and because people just
decided that he was a fascist because
they didn't really know what fascist
meant you know he said a lot of stuff
that I find contemptible and a lot of
stuff that I think you would be hard
pushed I think when he talked about in
an Omar and the squadron and said send
them how they can get they should just
go home I mean three of the four were
born in America and were born in America
and the fourth is a US citizen anyway
right it's difficult for me to see how
that can be interpreted as anything
other than a racist trope actually so
but this does not necessarily mean he's
a white supremacist that's a massive
leap to make again I'd meet the evidence
on it but yeah I think I think that's
the problem is that there's a sense of
frustration people were angry
understandably so you know it's not nice
to lose is it and it's easier if you can
then paint everyone in made that thing
happen is evil if you say that everyone
in vote for Trump is as deplorable as
Hillary Clinton or so memorably did and
that worked out really well for it
didn't it then of course you you go on
the offensive and you end up
guaranteeing Trump's victory in 2020
that's what you do that's what they've
done what would you predict what is
definitely a win
you reckon yeah I mean the way to play a
very smart game because he's putting
this the squad before Democrat
politicians who play identity politics
all the time so in an Omaha Alexandra
occasion Cortez Hannah Presley and and
receive Italy who are never going to
play well with the electorate because
they're always going on about grievance
and intersectionality and white
privilege and all that sort of stuff
that doesn't win votes never has never
will and what Trump is doing is he
constantly talks about them to make them
in the face of the Democrat policy so we
can answer to those giving them enough
rope yes napkin people like Pelosi I'm
hating this like sheet sheet she wants
to dismiss a set from from these four
but when you think Democrat now you
think goober woke crazy identitarian
right that's largely because of Trump
and because the way he puts him at sent
at the center so as a small tactical
move the Democrats needed
themselves from this kind of politics
identity politics never works and what's
so funny about why why doesn't work
because it divides everyone up it says
you know you stay in your lane over here
you stay in your lane we're gonna we're
gonna really help you will help the
Hispanics will help the gays will help
the women you know with anyone else I
think what about us what about us you
know and then becomes competing
competing interests you can only win an
election by unity by saying that we are
doing what's best for absolutely
everyone and because the worker movement
is essentially a movement that that
rehabilitates racial thinking it makes
us think about race more image think
about sexuality and it makes us aware to
the point of discrimination and it and
it and it separates us all out and it
wants to undo the work of the civil
rights movements it wants to undo the
work of Martin Luther King it wants us
no longer to think about content of
character but to think about color of
skin so it's a regressive backward
movement it isn't helpful human rights
it feeds the far-right it helps the
far-right the far-right is on the rise
they're still thankfully very fringe
group but they are on the rise because
of the woke movement because the woke
left giving them all the ammunition they
need ok because if you constantly say
that all these working-class white
people you're just privileged all you
boys you're just rapists in waiting you
know you've got toxic masculinity you
should be ashamed of yourself all of
this sort of stuff and then you've got
the alt-right white nationalist group
saying well come come to us then we're
not going to treat not because it
becomes an almost moderate and
attractive exact place to be exactly and
that's a really terrifying prospect for
me the main reason I attack the woke
left is because I'm scared of the rise
of the far-right that genuinely
frightens me because where is the woke
left or well intentioned on the whole I
think they're well-intentioned they want
they want the world to get a place
they're just in a cult so they can't see
the reality of it right you know it's
like anyone in a cult wicked they
they're believing they're believers
right it's not evil they see the world
as full of fascists they see the world
is full of injustice and they want to do
something about it that's a laudable aim
the problem is the world isn't for the
fascist and they just end up hitting
people with bite rocks because they vote
the wrong way right Sophia so that's
that's that's the problem all of that
does is generate all of this resentment
and and tow it's a gift it's a boon to
the genuine like really vile white
supremacist all right just just
repugnant people who can thrive on this
stuff but what you know that's as far as
I could see the only way to get beyond
that is to is to is to take down the
won't left to make it okay to mock them
again to restore reasonable political
conversation that's what we need to do
is so important
there must be so there's a really
interesting podcast Eric Weinstein on
Joe Rogan I can't Eric I've seen Joe
Rogan spoken up I haven't seen that so
Eric is the managing director of teal
capital Peter teal one of the PayPal
mafia yeah companies and he is fairly
widely regarded as one of the smartest
people like public intellectuals on it
and he has this really interesting point
he makes about how the moderates on both
the left and the right are allowing the
extremists of that side to do all of the
work for ya and then by not shouting up
as someone who's moderate left and
saying hang in a second that's wrong or
by being moderate right and saying hang
on a second that's also wrong right
Charlotte those children yeah whatever
it might be you are he says it with much
more nuance than this he says
essentially you're supporting it by not
by saying oh well you can you can go out
is the vanguard of your particular
political leaning yeah push them forward
a little bit yeah yeah I I think you
we can't shout shout louder than the
lunatics can do that they do they do
dominate they really do yeah I mean
that's a very good I think it's I think
friends in the case of Charlottesville
is it is quite important people on that
side of the debate to say this is wrong
it's you know it's it you know it's not
right for trumps to suggest a moral
equivalence between people who are
opposed to fascism and people who murder
in the name of white supremacy that's
not that's not right I mean the the the
the anti-fascist peaceful protesters I'm
behind 100% what I'm not behind is the
ones who donned the masks commit acts of
violence has a very different dragon old
man oh of his car and the driver
redirect him in traffic
right that's a very different it's
important because I think peaceful
protest is the way all the time peaceful
protests and ridicule but yes certainly
so so sorry to go back to the points
I've missed it I've gotten on different
extremes extremes pulling it for the for
the moderate people yeah well I think
that goes back to what Brigitte was
saying doesn't it is that when a
movement gets characterized by its worst
elements that's a problem in the way
that Islam for instance has been
mischaracterized by its most reactionary
elements and observed you get the same
thing here where suddenly you think of
the left I mean if I say the left what
do you think of you think of these
screeching offend seekers don't you you
think of the level here yeah you think
of the worst well actually that's not
being on the left means you know it's
and and that's a real shame so I think
yeah I think we need to restore
moderation I think we need to be we need
to stop having feel t-to ideology so
that we can say yeah
broadly speaking my principles are
left-wing but that that that you've just
said this right winger has said this
interesting thing which I might take on
board nap yeah we adopt as well mmm-hmm
and then and restore the nature of the
individual the individual is sovereign
as John Stuart Mill said like the it
matters what you think you have to have
to be a free thinker not let other
people do your thinking for you and
that's where we've got to where people
don't they don't do that anymore yeah
like if if you if you were on the Left
saying you told me one of your
principles I could pretty much guess
what all your other views are and that
should never be the case you should
surprise me now and then with what do
you think
[Music]